A homegrown chain, Muvi Cinemas, has opened up a pop-up  movie theater in Riyadh.
The facility has started featuring three showings per day.
The movie theater can accommodate up to 150 cars...
...while maintaining social distancing.
Some moviegoers have described the experience as exceptional...
...and enjoyable especially in Riyadh winter.
Audience members are required to wear face masks.
Viewers can buy food and drinks, but they have to take them in cars.
The organizers say they have applied all the precautionary measures...
...to ensure a safe environment for the employees and customers.
Drive-in cinemas popped up in other parts of the Middle East...
...since the outbreak of the coronavirus pandemic,...
...with similar venues opening up in Dubai and Beirut early last year.